what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch the
trailer for Meg to the trench where it
crosses over with Megan the doll I can't
wait to see a genre I I'll make some
Greg I'm ready to fight some sharks you
ready to chomp at the bit oh I'm ready
to sink my teeth into this trailer
ladies and gentlemen swim over to that
like button that would be amazing two
things I want to give a special thank
you for thank you number one is thank
you to everyone who bought yourself a
real exclusive space babies t-shirt at
shopzeroedition.com it is now on track
to becoming the number one best-selling
shirt at the real reject so thank you
guys so much secondly I want to say
thank you to everyone who came out to
the live show to the live show we did
yesterday John campia and Christian
harloff talking Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 gotta interact with so many guys
during and after the show as well for
those watch on pay-per-view thank you so
much and speaking of pay-per-view that
link will be available for at least one
whole week so you can catch the replay
there there's a link in the description
box and pin comments for both the shirts
and the pay-per-view link now let's see
what this show is all about
[Music]
the Jurassic boat
oh God are we going back
have we seen the origin
oh this is cool
Jason Statham
oh this is cool wow
where is it yeah
that's what I'm talking about cool Dale
I am that should be the movie is that oh
no dialogue
Jonas we need your help Joan ass if you
increase the quarterback activity 25 000
feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface nice
specific rip
this is a bad idea just a little bit
yes
way more fun this time yeah
that's good
I like that for them
Jonas
we've got company
goddamn right
that's the biggest night I've ever seen
the biggest Meg anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator the apex
predator
yes
more creatures
oh what happened
kick it in the nose
[Music]
when Jonas was always afraid of this but
I was also thinking why would you think
that's like the body count on this
trailer the dog's back
foreign
yes
oh my God oh my God that's what I'm
talking about
oh that shot back yeah it's a horrifying
shot
that looks fun it looks way more fun
yeah remember the last one being we only
saw that one time right I only saw that
one time with you in the theaters I've
watched it ten times it is one of your
top 10 movies of all time yeah that
first one I remembered being like a
little let down by I thought it'd be
more fun this looks like they have
really put the pedal to the metal on
this one they are jamming on that
acceleration that looks like a total
blast because like the body count in
this trailer was so high look I feel
like they took some notes on we need to
just ramp it up and looks are getting
multiple Megs versus like the Meg
leading multiple sharks like and there's
like other creatures now too that are
gonna be like more rising from the sea
well I mean it's doing what the T what
we thought would happen in Jurassic
World
um Dominion after the teaser ending of
Jurassic world Fallen Kingdom with the
creature in the water yeah that we did
not get more Aqua you know prehistoric
creatures and [__] like that it seems
like will be actually doing that a
little bit more here because the
beginning of this trailer was I imagine
if you're in the theaters it's supposed
to make you think you're watching like a
Jurassic World trailer right sure and
then they go bam we're actually it's a
Meg trailer so and and feels more
self-aware this time yeah well the thing
is the first movie is advertising felt
like they were taking something and
trying to make it look more
tongue-in-cheek than it actually was and
this seems like the fun is what the
movie is trying to be and is also trying
to communicate to you via this trailer
so I think they've done I get the sense
that they have done a couple things here
which is yeah listen to that criticism
of like this could be more balls to the
walls this could be more outwardly fun
just as a movie franchise and also I
mean I know this has been in production
and it's based on books and stuff but I
think there is that sort of idea that
they saw the Gap left by Jurassic world
because you know those movies make huge
money but are heavily debated in terms
of like fan satisfaction and we didn't
get that whole dinosaur overrun World
necessarily explored in that so I think
this is kind of a nice way to bridge
that Gap and maybe find something that
everybody can agree on is super duper
fun but isn't trying to be more or less
than it is I mean there are times where
you start to feel like you're dipping
into like a Sharknado world but at the
same time I mean just the effects look
great and I do hope that we get at least
a certain satisfying portion of just
that prehistoric angle because that's
part of the hook is like I mean that
shot at the end embodies everything that
terrifying image of the giantest shark
you've ever seen but also I mean there
is something cool about going back to
the prehistoric agent at least doing
something with that that you know
tickles people's fantasies and loves of
dinosaurs if they do a meg3 and people
are still going to the beach
bunch of idiots in this world yeah why
would you go to the beach it's already
hard to believe in Jaws when it's one
regular sized shark but when this is
like with like the size of like a an
aircraft carrier probably larger like I
don't know the actual scale but huge I'm
like yeah it seems like it wouldn't ever
be worth the risk it's near water is
this a different Beach this time yeah
yeah well that's the thing man maybe
maybe the third one they're gonna borrow
from Jaws three and it'll be like you
know this one particular Meg tracked
Jonas across the world yeah let's go to
Vendetta well there's a lot more Carnage
in this trailer yeah more of those kind
of cool shots of the teeth seems like
they're just leaning way more into it
this time and it feels more sci-fi yeah
a lot more of the kinds of uh marine
biology gear that they have equipped
themselves with get a little bit of that
you know spookiness that the Aquaman
canceled trench movie probably promised
you as well you're probably gonna get at
least a couple deep sea angler fish kind
of moment I just love that shot or Jason
Statham has his foot on the shark
what this [__] is happening in there to
get himself out of that position we're
leveraging himself off of its nose who
actually would do something one and two
it's like there's always that thing of
like if a shark's coming at you like
punch it in the nose but I'm like this
you're so small as compared to the size
of this thing it's not gonna feel you at
all I love that Jason Statham is a part
of you know he's he's part of these two
categories of like it's serious stoic
badass gritty Action Hero and then he's
now helming helping the helm two of the
most ridiculous franchise yeah exactly
Fast and Furious in the Meg franchise
maybe we'll see a high speed like jet
ski Chase or something like that just to
Bank off both fan franchises you know
yeah yeah that has had like a bit of a
Pacific Rim Vibe the first the first one
uh Pacific Rim all right guys well yeah
I mean we're working really say it's a
Meg trailer and there's shark Carnage
action and it was a lot of fun I had a
lot of fun with this one and I hope that
this movie delivers on the goods there
because this was a this was a fun one to
watch what did you guys think leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like last but not least want to
go ahead and end this with a pain
Lance door I want to see you go up
against a shark I feel like it would
just be so righteous to watch you hop
off the back of your fire engine thing
run down the beach stripping your shirt
off seeing your abs Rippling and pecks
glistening in the Sun as you selflessly
run toward nay away but toward the
danger only to punch that Meg Square in
the nose and send it packing and then
you can come back and like tame it learn
how to ride it and then you know you
would be the King of the Beach just like
you know Crest and waves you know
bringing joy and hope to all the people
and then crushing or you know devouring
anyone who gets in your way you could be
the real life Aquaman and Jason Statham
all rolled into one buddy so that's uh
that's that's your summer little gifty
there for you get to work and uh yeah we
love you we we have mega love for you
and we appreciate uh your support every
month and uh yeah just wanted you to
know that be well
that was a really good shout out well
thanks man
you're good at that time
this is all ants man it's all Lance
foreign
[Music]